billy you got to be on stage with bowie
singing all the young dudes
it was terrifying we did sound check as
you do and i thought it was weird
because he had me kind of about five
feet behind him so i thought it was a
bit of a dis
you know what i mean so i didn't
understand that so then i come out for
the show and it's about halfway through
the show and he's all warmed up and he's
sweating and i get oh
and he's doing that thing like his voice
is warmed up and it's that voice and it
was mind-blowing because to hear him
sing for real standing next to him and
for years i didn't understand why he
kind of put me behind him like it was
almost like a
like i'm the little kid with him and i
realized it was because i was so much
taller
he had done it to diss me wanted he
wanted us to look at the same height you
never know what yeah i mean the gears i
imagine
imagine he's david bowie and he gives a
[ __ ] about that at that point you know
but david was all about optics so now it
makes total sense that he would be
concerned that we look the same height
on on camera because he was very visual
but yeah he was always great to me i i
was i'm so blessed to have known him
this guy was such a [ __ ] genius the
thing about david that i think he's so
special to people from the alternative
music side is he could have been frank
sinatra he could have been like one of
those guys but he chose to just be a
weirdo like us
yes you know he's he's like our frank
sinatra you know i mean he's like our
weirdo but perry you pissed off boy do
you know this story billy i do not know
i'm shocked but i want to hear it
well it was it was not like i was
talking to him and i said something
wrong so what happened was
back in the day when cell phones were
just starting to happen i had this
blackberry you remember the blackberry i
just stopped using a blackberry a year
ago so i'm with you
so i left my blackberry in a cab on the
way to the airport and the cab driver
took it and went through it and saw
david bowie's name
so he called him up
yo
david
yes
uh
it's me
he's like oh the guy kept calling him
and i i had to finally say listen man it
wasn't me i'm really sorry that this
guy's bothering you
but i left my phone in the cab
so he forgave me right but then again
this was also at the same time
the beginning of the internet so i
didn't know what a cc a blind cc copy
was
sending an email
on an email
so
these people they they reached out to me
to see if i would help them save this
lake
and i got really excited about it and i
go you know i got all altruistic and i'm
going to help the world here and i
thought and i'm going to see if david
wants to do this too
so
i send him
this thing and i go david you've got to
help me save the fish in ontario you
know
what i didn't realize was there was 300
people along oh no
so again all these people started
hitting him up
and again he said perry what are you
doing i said well
i don't know what i'm doing i'm sorry
that was it that was that was the that
was almost it but it actually wasn't
just before he died
they had a show that they put together
he puts it together with tony viscanti
the
great producer of heroes
and he wanted me to do it so i was
thinking like oh man i'm gonna make up
with david this is great i can't wait
two weeks before the show he died
so i never got a chance to like
hey man i we we did it you know i didn't
screw up oh
that sucks yeah oh billy can you imagine
poor perry with david bowie because i'm
sure he was your
i was in love with him